Who are you
he is certainly not the mannequin
i arranged for you to bury
he is my beloved your father he is batman talia
race resurrected him in the lazarus pit my father
wouldn't risk the lazarus process after batman's
death in bosnia i would not stand by and allow
him such a trivial demise as my father feared
the pit drove bruce to madness but i chose my
beloved for his exceptional strength of mind
though his capacity for speech is
limited he has spoken with his body
and given himself to me you sick twisting when
batman dawned the colors of his former protege
it was clear he wanted you to join us and
i know bruce would never allow what batman
stood for to be corrupted by you neither will
i jason it is not me you must convince of that
soon
it was a long way back from where i'd gone but my
family took me back to heal so we could all heal
that's what family does to that end
barbara returned to duty as a sort of
oracle streaming live intel and support to
while he patrolled gotham i'm still working
through stuff not ready for the field yet but i am
finding the strength bruce saw inside me all along
the strength to just stop and heal the strength
to be part of a family now reunited to heal him
the effects of the lazarus pit made him a
danger to us to himself and to his legacy
a legacy we would protect
as we searched for a cure
with the hope that we might one
day save bruce wayne as he saved me
hey dad imagine if zorro came riding
through gotham on his horse right now
well bruce i'm not so sure a masked
vigilante would be welcomed in gotham city
sadly they probably just locked
someone like zorro and arkham
Welcome back everyone it's charlie this is going
to be my new batman red hood video for the new
under the red hood batman death in the family and
live-action red hood that they just announced so
we'll break it all down there's a bunch of easter
eggs and obviously a bunch of alternate endings to
this new movie choose your own red hood adventure
we'll do an amazon giveaway all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do with red hood in live action so
i'll start by explaining all the alternate endings
to this new batman red hood movie then i'll talk
about what's going on with the live action version
of red hood that they announced for titan season
3. so if you don't know what's going on they
just released a new movie called batman a death
in the family which is a retelling of a lot of the
events of batman under the red hood movie with at
least five or six different possible endings that
you can have it's sort of an interactive choose
your own adventure style movie retelling of the
red hood storyline the ending that i put at the
beginning of this video that clip is probably
my favorite one just because of the deep cut
easter eggs and how weird it gets but if you take
what i would call the original route where jason
todd dies at the hands of the joker you get the
original red hood storyline playing out the way
it did in that classic movie then what i'll call
the hush route is where he survives the blast but
goes crazy and eventually turns into a version of
hush so he survives the joker's blast batman kind
of saves him after the fact but he's horribly
scarred and his mind becomes really broken
and he swears revenge on batman blaming him for
his current state then it branches out into an
alternate league of assassins ending there's
almost three different league of assassins
endings that i'll explain talia tries to recruit
him in several of the different story lines in
the hush route he winds up accepting her offer
because he learns about the existence of damien
wayne batman is still alive so just in another
twist and trying to get revenge against batman
he swears to twist damien against batman and
use him as a weapon against the bat family in
the future just to twist the knife as much as
possible then the third main route which itself
leads to multiple separate endings is where
batman saves jason from the joker's explosion
but instead winds up dying himself and then that
leads to a bunch of different endings that are
separate from the other endings during that route
what happens is batman dies then grayson becomes
the new batman taking the cape and cow and jason
todd either one becomes a version of red robin two
still winds up becoming a version of red hood at
a different point in the timeline or three becomes
an unbranded criminal in prison the first league
of assassins ending during this storyline is the
clip that i put at the beginning of this where you
find out about Zur-En-Arrh batman and jason todd
saves him from talia then they take him back to
the bat family and they try to rehabilitate him
talia explains that back during the original
explosion she didn't want batman to die because
she was too important to her in the league
of assassin's mission so they resurrected him
but he came back crazy just like jason todd
came back crazy in the red hood story line
but the version of Zur-En-Arrh batman that they're
doing during this is actually based on the modern
version of the character so if you're not familiar
with who that is it's a super deep cut a super
weird version of batman that's a version of batman
that underwent hypnosis through a doctor wound up
repeating this mashup of his father's last words
zorro in arkham zorin ah then years later when
that doctor winds up working with black masks
they use the Zur-En-Arrh trigger to cause batman
to lose all of his memories and take up the zorina
identity forming a makeshift version of the batman
costume on the street that looks like the silver
age version of the costume all these weird colors
so he just winds up becoming a brainwashed version
of batman that goes a little nuts on the streets
so during that storyline jason has a bit of a
more positive ending barbara gordon becomes a
version of oracle because they have elements of
the killing jokes storyline during this joker
is a character during this batman death in the
family movie de grayson still continues to be the
main version of batman but they're never really
sure if bruce wayne is ever gonna get better
then the next alternate league of assassins ending
is the same version as you saw at the beginning
where jason todd shows up and he meets Zur-En-Arrh
batman but in that version of the ending batman
winds up killing them all with an explosion so
it's a bit of a downer ending that ends way faster
then in the ending where he doesn't become
hush he doesn't become red robin or become
red hood he winds up turning himself into prison
voluntarily to serve his sentence for crimes
and then takes the identity of jail bird serving
his own brand of justice inside the prison system
of gotham so there are a ton of alternate scenes
and alternate paths you can take then moving on
to the live-action version of red hood that they
just announced for titan season 3. they revealed
what his costume is going to look like it looks
a lot like the one from the arkham games sort
of a mashup of that in the comic book versions
the way they explained jason todd during titan
season 2 is they kept taking him to the brink of
death he was being sort of a daredevil playing it
fast and loose he almost died a couple times but
then because they were doing the teen titans judas
contract storyline he was sort of a core part
of that rose wilson wound up being the terror of
that situation the person inside the group that
was meant to infiltrate and then take them down
he was the one that advocated for bringing her
in and trusted her so when he found out what she
was really doing with her father deathstroke he
felt betrayed he took off he kind of went crazy
then the last thing you see of him during season
two is in the finale when they're burying donna
troy and passing her body back to the amazons
he's sitting on his motorcycle in the distance
and they sort of have this moment where they look
at each other and it's just to let you know that
he's going off on his own way for a long time
he's not going to be coming around anytime soon
so he takes off on his motorcycle and you're
just left to wonder how he gets from there
to red hood during season three how are they going
to explain it if he doesn't wind up dying because
that's a core part of him becoming red hood in the
comics getting resurrected in the lazarus pit but
coming back crazy so right now i think it's pretty
likely that the titans version of jason todd
doesn't wind up dying but just instead gets a
little brainwashed and still goes hardcore taking
the red hood mantle still killing criminals left
and right dropping bodies they're also bringing
barbara gordon onto the show but get it is older
barbara gordon who used to be batgirl but is now
commissioner in gotham so that's more like
the batman beyond version of barbara gordon
the only big batman villain that they've
announced so far is scarecrow he's going to
be one of the main villains and he's going to
be a profiler helping them from inside arkham
asylum so i'm assuming he might have something
to do with jason todd turning into red hood
but everyone post all your predictions for red
hood during titan season 3 in live action this is
as close as we've gotten to red hood in the movies
and if you guys didn't see talking about more red
hood easter eggs there's the dead robin in the
batman v superman justice league story line with
ben affleck's batman that's actually supposed to
be the grayson version at least in the zack snyder
canon but they're bringing back jared leto's joker
for new scenes in the justice league snyder cut
some people think that it's going to be flashbacks
to him killing robin but what'll happen is i have
some new mandalorian season 2 bonus videos to post
so i'll try to get those up as fast as possible
leave all your dc video requests in the comments
below congratulations rsr you're the giveaway
winner from my last big dc video please email me
on the about page of my channel so i can get your
contact details everyone click here for the new
star wars mandalorian season 2 episode 1 video
and click here to learn what's going on with
the new superman solo movie in man of steel 2.
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!